A SPOKESPERSON FOR CHINA'S
FOREIGN MINISTRY DEFLECTING
REPORTERS QUESTIONS ON PROTEST
AND LOOKING TO SEE IF CHINA IS
LOOKING TO END THE STRICT COVID
POLICIES.
>> IVAN WATSON IS IN HONG KONG,
HONG KONG HAS ITS OWN HISTORY OF
PROTESTS AND ALSO OF CRACKDOWNS.
YOU'VE SEEN SOME PROTESTS THERE.
PEOPLE DEFYING THE POLICE AS
WELL IN SOLIDARITY.
HOW EXTENSIVE?
>> WELL TWO KIND OF SMALL
DEMONSTRATIONS OF PEOPLE NOT
MORE THAN A HUNDRED DEMONSTRATE
YE
ORS AT THE ONE I VISITED A FEW
HOURS AGO BUT ALL THE MORE RARE
BECAUSE HONG KONG HAS BANNED
TERRITORYING AND CRACKDOWN ON
INDEPENDENT MEDIA AND OPPOSITION
POLITICAL PARTIES AND THROWN
ACTIVIST NEWS PRISON.
AND IT GOES TO SHOW HOW THE VERY
UNUSUAL NATIONWIDE PROTESTS THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN CHINA HAVE THIS
POWER TO KIND OF INSPIRE PEOPLE
HERE IN THE FORMER BRITISH
COLONY AS WELL.
I THINK THIS IS PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST NATIONWIDE MANIFESTATION
OF PUBLIC DISCONTENT THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN CHINA IN A GENERATION.
I SPOKE TO ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WAS OUT IN HONG KONG, A MAN WHO
ONLY WANTED TO GIVE HIS FIRST
NAME WHO IS FROM SHANGHAI, AND
HE DESCRIBED HIMSELF AS A VICTIM
OF CHINA'S ZERO COVID POLICY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I AM A VICTIM.
I CANNOT GO HOME.
FOR MANY YEARS.
LIKE TWO TO THREE YEARS, RIGHT.
MY PARENTS WERE LOCKED DOWN FOR
TH
THREE MONTHS.
AND EVEN RELATIVES OF MY GOOD
FRIENDS, THEY HAD SUICIDE
BECAUSE OF THE LOCKDOWNS.
RIGHT.
AND I KNOW PEOPLE DIE BECAUSE OF
IT.
BECAUSE OF THE SIDE EFFECTS OF
THIS POLICY, RIGHT.
I THINK EVERYONE WHO HAS A SANE
MINDP SHOULD SAY SOMETHING OR DO
SOMETHING TO STOP THIS
UNREASONABLE SOCIAL MEASURE.
>> Reporter: NOW, WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CONFIRM 16 SEPARATE
PROTESTS IN MAINLAND CHINA
ACROSS 11 DIFFERENT CITIES.
AND OF COURSE WE HAVE REPORTS OF
ADDITIONAL PROTESTS BUT IT IS SO
HARD TO MAKE SENSE OF THAT AND
CONFIRM IT AND VERIFY IT GIVEN
THE INTENSE CENSORSHIP ON THE
MAIN LAND.
>> JUST INCREDIBLE TO SEE THESE
PROTESTS IN SEVERAL CITIES.
>>> JOINING ME NOW IS BRONNY
LYNN, WORKED AT PENTAGON ON
TAIWAN AND CHINA ISSUES.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON THIS
MORNING.
>> THANK YOU, JIM, THANK YOU,
BIANNA.
>> SO LET'S BEGIN, THESE ARE
UNUSUAL AND COURAGEOUS BECAUSE
OF THE PRICE THAT PEOPLE PAY FOR
DISSENT IN CHINA.
AND THEY'RE NATIONAL, LEAST IN
MANY LARGE CITIES, DO THEY POSE
A GENUINE THREAT TO THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT?
>> I THINK RIGHT NOW IT IS A BIT
EARLY TO SAY THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
ON DAY TWO AND A HALF OR THREE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LARGE SCALE
PROTESTS THAT HAS HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON I THINK
TIANANMEN IN 1989 IS THE BEST
EXAMPLE, IT STARTED IN APRIL AND
WE DIDN'T SEE THE CULMINATION OF
THE EFFECT UNTIL JUNE.
SO WE STILL HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME TO SEE HOW MUCH THIS WILL
SPREAD AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW IS AT LEAST 16
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
BUT WE STILL DON'T HAVE A SENSE
OF HOW LARGE THIS IS.
IT SEEMS LIKE EACH LOCATION IS A
COUPLE HUNDRED PEOPLE PER
LOCATION.
AND IF IT IS SPREAD OUT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, IT IS ACTUALLY NOT
TOO DIFFICULT FOR CHINA TO CLAMP
DOWN, IF IT IS ONLY A COUPLE
HUNDRED PER LOCATION.
BUT IF WE SEE TENS OF THOUSANDS
IN ONE LOCATION, I THINK
PARTICULARLY AS IT GET CENTERED
AROUND BEIJING, THAT IS MUCH
MORE OF A CHALLENGE FOR THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO DEAL WITH.
>> BUT THE FACT THERE ARE
ALREADY 16 PROTESTS TELLS YOU
THAT CHINA'S VERY POWERFUL
CENSORSHIP MACHINE HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO ACT QUICKLY ENOUGH TO
TAKE DOWN SOME OF THE VIDEOS AND
POSTS DENOUNCING ZERO COVID
POLICY, DENOUNCING XI JINPING
HIMSELF.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
THEIR LIMITATIONS BECAUSE THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE SEEN
THEM CHALLENGED TO THIS EXTENT
UNDER XI JINPING?
>> THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO SEE TO
WHAT EXTENT THE MEASURES THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN
INCLUDING MORE POLICING, MORE
ARRESTS, MORE CENSORSHIP, TO
WHAT EXTENT THIS WILL CURB THE
PROTESTS MOVING FORWARD.
SO WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS, FOR
EXAMPLE, TONIGHT, MONDAY NIGHT
OR TOMORROW, IF THIS WILL
CONTINUE TO ESCALATOR IF CHINA
WILL HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SORT OF
TONE THIS DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
BUT I WOULD SAY EVEN IF WE SEE
MORE PROTESTS GROWING THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DAYS, WE DON'T SEE THE
SAME POLITICAL CONDITIONS THAT
WE SAW THERE 1989 WHICH WAS A
VERY DIVIDED CHINESE LEADERSHIP
IN WHICH ONE LEADER COULD TAKE
THE FALL FOR THIS.
RIGHT NOW WE SAW XI JINPING
CONSOLIDATE POWER IN THE 2022
CONGRESS.
I DON'T SEE ANY MAJOR
CHALLENGERS TO HIM RIGHT NOW.
SO IT COULD BE POSSIBLE ONE OF
HIS DEPUTIES TAKE THE FALL BUT I
DON'T SEE XI JINPING TAKING THE
FALL.
>> HE'S ELIMINATED CHALLENGERS.
AND LET'S TALK ABOUT CHINA'S
ZERO COVID POLICY WHICH SPARKED
WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
CL
CHINA TRIED TO RELAX THEM BUT
THEN FORCED TO TIGHTEN
RESTRICTIONS AGAIN BECAUSE CASES
WENT UP.
THE FACT IS, IT IS COVID POLICY
IS FAILING.
REALLY THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MEDICAL RESOURCES TO HANDLE IT
IF MORE AND MORE PEOPLE GET
SICK.
WHAT CAN XI JINPING AND THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT DO
REALISTICALLY TO TOOK THE COVID
POLICY TO GIVE SOME GROUND TO
THESE PEOPLE OR CAN'T IT?
>> SO CHINA IS NOW AT RECORD
NUMBER OF COVID CASES.
A LITTLE BIT UNDER 40,000.
AND JUST TO PUT THIS IN CONTACT,
THAT IS AROUND THE SAME NUMBER
THAT THE UNITED STATES HAS.
BUT THIS IS THE OFFICIAL CHINESE
REPORT.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS THE
ACTUAL NUMBER.
IT COULD BE MUCH LARGER.
MAIN ISSUE AS YOU MENTIONED IS
THE VACCINES.
RIGHT.
WE KNOW THAT ABOUT 90% OF
CHINA'S POPULATION IS VACCINATED
BUT ONLY 60% OF ITS ELDERS ARE
ACTUALLY BOOSTED.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT CHINA'S
VACCINES DON'T WORK QUITE AS
WELL AS OUR MRNA VACCINES.
SO AS CHINA LOOKED FORWARD, THE
MAIN ISSUE IS CAN IT AFFORD TO
OPEN UP AT THE RISK OF LARGE
NUMBERS OF ITS POPULATION
POTENTIALLY CONTRACTING THE
VIRUS AND THEN DEPENDING ON
THEIR VACCINATION OR IF THEY'RE
NOT VACCINATED, THEY COULD BE AT
RISK OF DYING OR SEVERE
COMPLICATIONS.
>> AND CHINA HAS NOT IMPORTED
THE BETTER MRNA VACCINES.
BONNIE LYNN, GREAT TO HAVE YOU
ON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WANT TO TALK MORE ABOUT THIS,
THESE LOCKDOWNS AND THE COVID
POLICY.
DR. AMESH ADALJA IS A SENIOR
SCHOLAR FROM THE JOHN HOPKINS
CENTER FOR HEALTH SECURITY,
JOINING ME LIVE.
DOCTOR, WE ARE SEEING CASES
RISE, BUT THE REALITY THERE IS
THAT THESE LOCKDOWN MEASURES
HAVE LED TO IMMENSE HUMAN
SUFFERING ACROSS CHINA.
AND AS I SAY, RISE, IRONICALLY
IN CASES WHERE PERHAPS, NOT
IRONICALLY.
BUT WHAT IS YOUR VIEW ON THIS
ZERO COVID STRATEGY?
AND DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO YOU?
>> ZERO COVID HAS NEVER MADE
SENSE TO ME.
WHEN YOU TRY TO IMPLEMENT IT,
IT IS A COMPLETE FAILURE.
THIS STEMS FROM THE FACT THAT
THIS IS A VIRUS THAT CANNOT BE
ERADICATED, ELIMINATED.
IT TRANSMITS EFFICIENTLY, AND
WAS ALWAYS DESTINED TO BECOME
AN ENDEMIC.
YOUR GOAL WITH COVID-19 IS
ALWAYS BEEN TWO SEPARATE CASES
FROM HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
DEATHS, TO REMOVE THE ABILITY
OF THE VIRUS, TO CRUSH
HOSPITALS, NOT TO ERADICATE OR
ELIMINATED, THAT IS A FANTASY.
UNFORTUNATELY, PEOPLE IN CHINA
HAD TO SUFFER FOR SO LONG
BECAUSE OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENTS APPEARING TO KIND
OF FANTASTICAL THINKING THAT IS
NOT BASED IN REALITY.
>> FOR THOSE I MEAN, ZERO COVID
POLICY HAS MEANT VERY FEW
PEOPLE, THE NUMBERS ARE TICKING
UP, HAVE ACTUALLY HAD COVID.
WHICH MEANS, I GUESS, CORRECT
ME IF I AM WRONG, IT IS MUCH,
MUCH MORE LIKELY AS THEY COME
OUT OF COVID, THAT CASES WILL
TAKE UP THERE IS NO IMMUNITY,
CORRECT?
>> THERE'S NO IMMUNITY FROM
INFECTION BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN INFECTED.
THEY DO HAVE A FAIRLY HIGH
VACCINATION RATE IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION.
BUT WE KNOW THOSE VACCINES ARE
PROBABLY NOT AS EFFECTIVE AS
THE WESTERN VACCINES.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE THIS IMMUNITY GAP,
WHICH WILL INCREASE CASES.
I THINK IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
FOR CHINA TO FOCUS ON
PROTECTING THOSE AT RISK FOR
HOSPITALIZATION BY PUTTING
EFFECTIVE VACCINES INTO THEM,
GETTING DRUGS LIKE PAXLOVID
AVAILABLE, MAKING SURE THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY, RATHER THAN
THIS UNSUSTAINABLE APPROACH
THAT CAN NEVER AND BASED ON
WHAT THIS VIRUS IS.
IF THEY STICK TO THIS, THERE IS
NO END IN SIGHT.
IT WILL LEAD TO UNTOLD
SUFFERING, BOTH OF PEOPLES
LIVES, AND ECONOMICALLY FOR
THEIR COUNTRY.
>> SO IF THE LOCKDOWN WERE TO
BE DROPPED, WHAT WOULD THAT
LOOK LIKE IN CHINA, GIVEN
CURRENT CASES AND VACCINE RATES,
TO YOUR MIND?
>> WHAT WE WOULD SEE IS A SURGE
IN CASES.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE
ANYTHING SURPRISING.
THE VIRUS IS THERE, IT WILL
SPREAD.
THE QUESTION IS HOW MANY
HIGH-RISK PEOPLE WILL BE
INFECTED?
WE KNOW THAT CHINA THINGS
BACKWARDS, THEY DID NOT MAKE
THE VACCINE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE
ABOVE 60 EARLY ON.
WE KNOW THAT IS STILL TRICKLING
DOWN.
THERE'S NOT THAT MANY HIGH RISK
PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED.
SO I DO THINK THAT WE WOULD SEE
A SURGE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
DEATHS AMONG THE HIGH-RISK,
WHETHER WE CAN HANDLE THAT
CAPACITY, THAT IS A QUESTION
THAT ONLY THEY COULD ANSWER
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
BUILD HOSPITALS VERY QUICKLY.
THE POINT IS, THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO THIS AT SOME POINT.
THEY HAVE HAD TWO AND A HALF
YEARS TO USE MRNA VACCINES IN
THE POPULATION, BUT THEY HAVE
REFUSED THEM.
SO TO ME IT IS NOT A SITUATION,
OF THEIR COMPLETE DOING.
IT REALLY REFLECTS UTTER
INCOMPETENCE FROM THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT TO ALLOW THIS TO
FESTER ON, FOR TWO AND A HALF
YEARS WITH THIS MATTER, WITH
THIS MAGICAL THINKING.
>> FASCINATING, ISN'T IT?
THANK YOU, DR..